Your goal is to create a similar data frame to
the fc_by_age one. This time though, we wanted it to have
friend counts by age months instead of age years. Here's one
solution that you might have done, by chaining the operations of
dplyr together. So first, I want to make sure that
the library is loaded and then I'm going to create my data
frame, pf.fc_by_age_months. So, I'm going to take my original data frame and
apply a bunch of functions to it, from the dplyr package.
First, I'll group by age with months, then I'll chain on
a new command called summarize, and here I want to summarize by
friend count mean, and friend count median, and the number of
users in my group. And finally, I'll chain on one more command
that will arrange my data frame by age with months. Running
this command, I can see that I have my new data frame.
Notice too, that I have a lot more observations. And that
should make sense, because I went from age years to age months.
And just to be sure, I'll print out a couple
rows on my data frame to examine it. There's my age
measured in months, my friend count mean, my friend count
median, and n, the number of users in each group. Now,
there was another way to get the same data frame.
Let's see how we can do that. Instead of chaining the
commands together, I can use the data frame and then
apply commands to it. So first, I'll create age_with_months.groups. I'll use
that using the group.by command. I'll pass it my data
frame, and then I want to group, by age_with_months. That's the variable.
Now that I have my groups, I want to summarize them
using mean friend count, median friend count, and in, which is
the number of users in each group. So here I'll
summarize age-with-months, and I'll save it into this new variable. Now
that I have my groups, I want to summarize them using
the Summarize command. I'll create
a new data frame called, pf.fc_by_age_months2.
I want to summarize this data frame, since it's already in
groups. So I'll pass it here. Age_with_month groups. Now I just need
to add the variables that I want to summarize. I want the
mean of friend count, so I'll save that to a variable, I
want the median friend count so I'll also save that to
a variable. And finally I want the number of users in each
age group. Now I just want to take this data frame and
arrange it by age_with_months. So I'll pass this data frame into the
arrange function, and then I'll tell it to
arrange by age_with_months. Notice, too, that I'm saving
this new data frame into our old data
frame, so I'm just writing it over. Running
all this code, we can see that we get our new data frame, and we can
also check it just by using our head
function. Sure enough, the same exact data frame.